disengage it did you watch the game just
tell me did you watch the game how are
you should i spray the mic did the last
person have a disease oh no you're
talking now does Ono are you it might
smell or the yes it smelled like spit
and feet Oh what do you it was like
lavender
yo it's um what a smart thing to do
right so it smells better
yeah do you smell like somebody's mouth
or a mic I'll use my oh my thing it's
because it's disgusting
[ __ ] how much it stinks sometimes your
mouth touches it right have you done
that before when you're doing like
another radio station and like you
leaned in to do something or something
and all of a sudden your lips make
contact me like oh dude you try not to
do that a microphone in a comedy club
right oh yeah in a comedy club so you
see I like a little like bits of stuff
it's terrible the microphones are gross
guys who travel with their own mics I
get yeah
yes you should do that you should start
doing it though like a pop star like a
like a diamond encrusted like pink
microphone like everybody knows Jim's
here yeah they should they see that
magical mic up and that's like my thing
yeah pink is good for it is right I
would like that mastery enough to pull
it off yeah yeah how are you Pam that's
pretty good to see you I'm really good
thank you
I can't believe it's been a year sat in
this room this is crazy
close to it yeah I know we were doing
test shows last summer yeah that's right
it has been a year so you've been going
to like you were at the Emmys with Louie
yeah are you guys getting married we're
never we're never gonna get married no
are you happy to not be married you guys
are both like divorce so you like have
freedom and you happy I I've I pinching
myself
I'm so happy in my life right now put
away my kids are all okay they're all
older you know my two youngest are in
high school
the baby's in high school now right
remember her Jesus she wasn't even two
when we did lucky Louie Wow and it's
it's unbelievable like you know I have
five jobs you know and to look at my
life like the past decade
- now I can't even believe it I'm right
you can't I mean it's hard work it's
hard work but it's good though he's nice
to worry it sucks not doing anything I I
couldn't do it
are you seen my Tiger tea I haven't the
guy we were talked about before right I
haven't seen him or I haven't seen the
woman who played Kim I remember her name
Kim Hawthorne all right all right I
haven't seen her
I played Kim you mean Jerry minors Jerry
minors wife yeah yeah Kim Hawthorne
Laura kite Langer Oh her real name was
Kenneth I remembered her real name
that's right okay that's right so when
you have like when you're at this place
where you love your life and you've
worked hard hard hard and now he's
finally like yes I love my life right
now
do you write are you are you constantly
afraid of it like listen what do I do
when I was shooting this season which
was a 40 day shoot 10 episodes all on
location cross boarded two countries to
cruise I was keeping my head low I was
like okay I'm short timing like I'm
something's good you know what I mean
life is like that you know it's like you
know when things are bad you expect
things to explode because it's you're
going down this rat hole and then when
things are good you're like you know
when's this you gonna drop or something
like that so you can't think that way
you just need to make the most of the
time that you're living in and just kind
of be in the moment and enjoy like this
is great right now yeah and you have to
keep the momentum going because you know
my dad always said irons in the fire
I know he was a writer and producer and
so he would just constantly have like
this is what the walls of his office
would look like they were peppered with
like post-it notes and like ideas and
brain bits he would call them so it's
like so now I have two seasons of my
show under my belt the second season
just started airing but I'm thinking
about other things because I have the
ability to make work for myself and
other people now I don't want to lose
this opportunity I was able to do my
show because I had this window of
opportunity and it was getting small
and smaller and jumped through at
probably the only moment I could have
done it see what I like to do is let a
window of opportunity completely shut
and get cemented over and then my
manager goes for you now especially now
that like like it worked you realize
that the window of opportunity thing is
a real thing so now it's like you have
to be constantly aware of where these
windows of opportunities are so you
don't miss them like is that something
that you're like well it's just like you
know I would imagine people who have
their own office you know one day when I
you know when I was younger and now you
know I have an office and so I can
generate material and things like that
and it's like it just feels good to be a
boss you know what I mean and to not
have to just sit there and go well I
gotta wait for pilot season maybe I'll
get an episode of Jake and The Fatman
or maybe even a two-episode arc or
something you know is that still on I
don't know but this is a great reference
I haven't heard that you probably won't
be able to do that show today just have
to change it to something else be body
shaming yeah you know yeah to see your
names on here and it's all like a new
thing I love it that's true but it's
only on screens where they can
immediately put the next show up there's
nothing's our plastic it's on we bring
the plastic things home and we want them
but they did who they were like oh this
is gonna be great because it used to be
they would make walls and your names
would be printed on the walls and then
they go be like this is great whatever
it's permanent and then they go oh we
got something even better we're gonna
get screens in here and put your names
on the screens and you're like yeah it's
digital and then you're like in it you
could just it's like a parking space you
just change it exactly yeah you just
remove the sign how did I never know cuz
I've known you for so long maybe I knew
this and forgot to projects you were in
that I didn't realize III didn't realize
you were in little darlings the film
with Armand Assante I wasn't in
movie I did the pilot of the movie I was
the Kristy McNichol part why would he be
the pilot of the movie we did a pilot of
little darlings and I was there was
Ferris and what was what was my name I
was the I was the Kristy McNichol
character but it never got picked up
yeah
oh there was a pilot after the movie
yeah oh okay okay yeah we shot it on the
Laverne and Shirley stage oh did you get
to meet them I didn't but I I mean I met
Penny Marshall years later like doing a
voiceover thing with her but um Garry
Marshall came over when we were on the
set we were having a food fight and he
said this is a great place take care of
it have fun kids
and they didn't pick us up okay so
that's and also I didn't realize you had
a 12-episode thing in the facts of life
I don't know what did you play I played
Kelly Ofunato I robbed Edna's edibles
and I held up mrs. Garrett well that's
great I dropped a jar of pickles and
they caught me red-handed yeah well they
[Laughter]
know here's here's the real story they
hired me to be a new kid they wanted me
to be like the tomboy a joke they wanted
me to be Joe that's in MacKinnon
originally it was gonna be like Joe's
cousin and so then they hired me to do
for one season and basically I was told
that she did not want this new character
or her people or something yeah so then
basically I was told they went to the
network with a red pen every week and so
basically instead of being this like you
know homeless kid or whatever they
turned me into a rich kid liar okay
you still got on the show I was very uh
I it was like my dream come true and
then like my hopes were dashed I only
ended up doing um seven out of like 22
episodes
however to you would they treat you all
or no you know Kim fields was amazing
she was very sweet and Mindy Cohn still
friends with her oh you liked her she
was nice how is Lisa welcher she was a
fan of reading Christian fiction really
really yeah
she I don't oh my god hey is that your
copy of Christ scores a touchdown yes
Margaret I'm here do you know that Joe
doesn't want you on the show like when
you get there do you find that out later
I got wind of it it was kind of a bummer
was she not nice to you um but you know
she was she was nice
she was cordial cordial be there well
and it's funny you're much bigger than
she is now like it's odd how those
things happen like you're on top of the
world and then you don't treat somebody
well you work against somebody and it's
like and now look at how things are yeah
I've never actually told the real story
yeah this is all been coming my way your
entire career has been a revenge plot
against Joe from the finish line this is
what it's all for
that's all I were talking about you're
much nicer than me I'm very soon as I
won that Emmy in 2002 and I'd be like
where are you now ed you do wow you did
you won for Hall hold on a second
kicking the hell king a voiceover yeah
you could do it in the Bobby Hill voice
oh that's right the good Joe
I was pregnant with my youngest at that
point she was born in 2003 did you go up
and accept or do they not always oh wow
I did that was at the schmemmys you know
what we call the schmemmys the creative
arts awards so they hold those of the
week before the Emmy is still amazing it
was incredible what what it
was is it's a juried award so um a jury
of my peers voted to give me the Emmy so
I was told beforehand while you were and
which I I still couldn't believe it when
they told me and I was I was very
pregnant when I went to the Emmys and
the story about that is I went with my
mom and Steven root and his wife who
played bill on king of the hill and so
we were on the red carpet and the woman
who made my outfit I was super pregnant
and the only accessory I wore was my
giant tits and I was on the red carpet
and I said oh I gave my camera to
stephen root and i said take a picture
of me for rachel who had made the outfit
for me and he was taking a picture of me
and somebody said can you move along
Paula Abdul is coming and I was like
[ __ ] her I wouldn't have me move it
along
but it was it was it was an amazing
experience to be able to to get honored
in that way yeah this kind of feel the
people say oh it doesn't matter but it's
still nice definitely matters or is that
show coming are they are they talking
about reviving that show I have no but I
mean you know what I mean it's like they
ask you questions like that at the CCS
and I think that probably Mike and Greg
were in a conversation but I I've no I'm
not a clue I don't know you would do it
though oh hell yeah oh you would do you
would go back to doing it of course
voiceover stuff is hard to get I get
auditions for it sometimes but I don't
do you know did you do any fun voices
yeah yeah no I difficult to do because
you don't know what they're looking for
yeah you should do something animated
like your voice I do a podcast that
people are now animating and people are
actually enjoying that this version of
the animation but IIIi hit this one I
forgot to do yesterday for DreamWorks
you forgot to do over my closet which
you know how comfortable I am in there
at your home but no it's it's very
soundproof it's really good I thought it
was under the porch yeah start on the
Porsche you can walk into the old nice I
have a nice built-in nice walk-in closet
but it's good for this purplevelvet you
forgot to do it
I did yeah by just I get them all the
time they email I'm to do it to your
iPhone you have a voiceover agent I do
yes yes okay good luck apparently you
know she's certainly not eating what
she's not eating well if she's lying on
my [ __ ] checks hopefully she's other
clients hopefully her hope on me
hey how about grease to my first movie
movie yeah my first movie and I was like
oh my god I couldn't believe that I was
playing Lorna Luft little sister because
she was Judy Garland's daughter and
freaked me out I had the best time when
she lies his sister she is well her
father was Sid left and Liza's father
was Vicent the tenth day Minelli okay
but yeah my first movie I loved it it
was amazing I was like 14 years old and
everybody else was like 40 the kid on
the set yeah it was it was fun I saw
that Michelle Pfeiffer was at the Emmys
the other night I never got to say hi to
her and she was my buddy when we shot
you have you seen her since then I saw
her a few years after but it's been
years 25 years since you've talked to
her it's a mission for Renaissance
happening he's a movie mother she's in
the Bernie Madoff HBO movie yeah she's
doing a bunch of stuff for dancing
Scarface should have won her an Oscar
that was my Connie she was so good that
good I don't [ __ ] the help Tony good
film so you audition for this you get
this your first film is there like a
lolly after that or do you go right into
something else after Greece - yeah I did
the little darlings but not the first
thing you did that didn't get picked up
like like that was your first like
reality check like wow you could shoot
something that's not yeah it was it was
um yeah that's when but Greece to the
auditioning for Greece do I saying you
can't get a man with a gun was my
audition song and look at me I'm Sandra
Dee and then or Sandra Dee how is it
and then the the last audition was the
table read for the movies so the entire
cast was sitting around the table and
they had this oh you know what I did the
pilot before because it was the girl who
played Ferris in the little darlings
pilot and me and we literally sat next
to each other and she would read one
line as Dolores and I would read the
other which is so [ __ ] mean that's
crazy pressure so that's how we did it
and then at the end they took us in the
back to meet Maxwell Caulfield so she
went and then I went and we did this
audition scene and he said why don't you
let me walk you home and I said and and
I said I don't need I don't need you to
mark me home and he goes well why don't
you think of it as a date okay and I
look him up and down I stared at his
balls and then I looked at his face and
I said why didn't you say so in the
first place and he was so handsome he
was like the most beautiful thing you've
ever seen and I got the part I think cuz
I stared it as Dee smart we have to wrap
up in 30 seconds that's the greatest
story I've ever heard
that's exactly how I got hired here is
wrapped up sitting here that's
phenomenal scared of this balls